president biden spent much of this week
focusing more on foreign
than domestic policy he announced a
withdrawal date for u.s troops in
afghanistan and sanctions against
russia for its acts of aggression
against the u.s
christina raffini is at the white house
christina good morning to you
good morning jeff as you mentioned since
coming to office president biden has
really tried to focus on domestic issues
right
covet economic relief infrastructure but
as his own secretary of state likes to
say
foreign policy is domestic policy and
this week
there was a lot of it and i'm really
pleased to welcome such a close ally
and good partner japanese prime minister
yoshihiresuga
is the first world leader to be hosted
by president biden at the white house
a show of solidarity aims at america's
biggest strategic competitor
we committed to working together to take
on the challenges from china
the biden administration wants to turn
its foreign policy
focus away from the middle east and
redeploy those resources towards
countering russia and china
we'll be much more formidable to our
adversaries and competitors over the
long term
if we fight the battles for the next 20
years
not the last 20. this week the president
announced he will pull
all u.s forces out of afghanistan by
september 11th
the president made the decision to start
the drawdown on
may first and that's the plan that we're
going on the white house
also unveiled sweeping action against
moscow
expelling 10 russian officials
sanctioning dozens of
others and officially blaming russian
intelligence services for the massive
computer hack known as solar winds
obviously we've put sanctions in place
in order to send a clear message that
there should be consequences for the
actions
but there were consequences for the
consequences with the kremlin yesterday
announcing its own sanctions
and saying it plans to expel 10 american
officials
a move the state department called
escalatory and regrettable
and there was another foreign policy
dust up over refugee policy the white
house appeared to announce it would keep
the cap for refugees allowed in the
country
at 15 000 which was an historic low set
by the previous administration
but after a lot of pushback from
democrats and human rights groups
the white house said it was reevaluating
and there would be a higher number
announced
later this month christina thank you